comedy Mothership in Austin Texas this
club it's too hard to resist shout out
to Joseph Rogan everything is utter
Perfection it's perfect it's a perfect
Club perfect Vibe it's just runs so
right it's amazing it's so state of the
art the club is just fantastic it's the
best club in the country best sound I've
ever heard the most beautiful Club
that's ever been imagined it's already
the greatest Club I've been in the
layout the seating The Green Room the
sound system top notch it was almost
like it was
a comedy club designed by a comedian who
has unlimited money what he has created
is insane he's like the new version of
Mitzi Shore on behalf of my mom too I'm
so proud of you dude it reminds me of
like the great clubs
in the country it's The Comedy Store of
steroids that's all I can say
Aerosmith is Aerosmith Guns and Roses is
Aerosmith on steroids